no I'm fine I'm thanks skinny minute so
yes this particular black mayor review
is earlier than I have been doing them
this had been Wednesday fixture but
legions coming back and that's gonna
take over the Wednesday slot and I'm
almost of a black mirror anyway so
that's getting moved forward to
Tuesday's and that's how I'll wrap up
the last few of these but right now we
got to talk about San Junipero and
reminder spoilers up there in the title
so yeah that that got to me in a good
way and a lot the the what was
impressive about it was I was not caught
off guard by really anything that
happened in this including the tone of
the ending this I can actually blame you
guys for down in the comments because
various things folks have said in
various one-off comments across other
reviews I think most of them were said
in relation to hang the DJ I at least
picked up the fact that San Junipero
does not end in an existential black
hole of sinking dear God what's the
point of everything that most black
mayor episodes tend to end with I knew
it ended on a positive note I didn't
know anything beyond the specifics of
that but I knew that it had whatever
version of a happy ending that black
mirror tends to do so in a way that was
kind of spoiled to me I think it
would've it probably would have been
even more impactful for me than it was
if I had been expecting everything to go
to hell like it usually does and it
didn't because that was one of the
things that I liked about hang the DJ
but I actually liked this episode as a
whole more then I liked hang the DJ so
if this if I hadn't known that this was
gonna end well and you know that had
that had been in a way the twist boy
this would have been this would've been
catapulted right near the top for these
things but let's let's not get ahead of
ourselves
feels as we go along because there were
there were plenty of them but in any
case I really like the lead actresses
they were both charming and enjoyable to
watch and had great chemistry together
so that was that was a that was a big
win the diamond it really is pretty much
just them which I liked I got worried
when we saw you know the guy that we see
kind of pursuing Kelly a couple of times
and I was afraid that he was gonna keep
showing up and be like twisted by
obsession or something but they didn't
go there his purpose was to cast seeds
of doubt in your key and that why boy I
will say you're he I'm glad they didn't
say that name out loud a lot beyond the
very opening because it's spined of a
dumb name it's right up there I saw
bound not all that long goes right up
there with the fact that one of those
characters is called Corki oh boy but
like I think that's probably gonna be my
only nitpick but you know the reason
that that male character was there was
you know to just to put that seed of
doubt in her and so once he did that he
was gone and he didn't take over the
narrative or you know he'd become like
oh this is what's gonna mess everything
which was great he was there for the
purpose that he needed to be there and
then he was gone so the it it really did
hinge on these two characters in these
two actresses and they are both really
good they're really good in this and and
also the character plays old Kelly uh
also needed to sell that pretty good and
she did she did it quite well and Greg
was nice Greg was a sweet guy and I like
the pace at which things sort of not
unravel but kind of reveal themselves
because I I mean watching it I was like
holy cow could this possibly be any more
80s and it wasn't very long into it
until I thought to myself I would not be
shocked if this is like a simulation
that is just trying to be as ease as
humanly possible which it is basically
what it was so
I'm likes it even aside from the fact
that I knew from comments and stuff that
this ended this ended happily I did
pretty much see every twist coming the
fact that this was an artificial reality
I guess that at least as possibility
pretty early on and when it was revealed
that some of the folks they are you know
are quote unquote permanent residents ie
not alive in the real world that I don't
I didn't necessarily call that ahead of
time but that wasn't a huge relief from
some of the places my head had gone up
to that point and then figuring out you
know that um you know these two women
that at least one of them was was about
to die and end up there and all that so
you know nothing about the way things
played out or you know even some of the
the reveals about your CUSO like when we
found out she was in a car crash I'm
like the instant we saw her in there
like a car crash because I remembered
like one of the first things we see from
her she flinches just seeing a video
game cabinet that's a racing game it has
a car crash in it and so I mean called
that right off the bat but at the same
time it doesn't this is not about the
the plot machinations this is not even
really about the technology this is
about two people this is about two
people connecting and in a way that
probably neither of them were really
prepared for at least on the level that
had happened and the point at which this
first started really connecting to me is
the second time when your key goes back
to the club and she sees Kelly like
across the way and Kelly's talking to
another guy and starts dancing on the
floor there and they kept catching each
other's eye and speaking of someone who
has basically been on both sides of that
particular equation it does a really
good job of capturing that sense of
being on the sidelines and feeling god I
wish they would catch my eye again oh
they did did they
you two will they look at me again do
they want to be looking at me you know
is is this a signal should I be acting
on this or being of a flip side you know
catching this person's eye who's not
who's not actively engaging yet and you
keep hoping come on get what get what
I'm saying to you
please come on reel in on this
connection I'm throwing out there and I
think it captured both sides of that
really really well there was there was
something that your key said that really
and then this was early in the episode
she said to Kelly please make this easy
for me I'm not even sure I can properly
articulate why that line choked me up I
think it's it's something about just
being knowing that something will be
good but being scared by it and wanting
to go there but it's hard and you wish
it wasn't and yeah it was just something
about that line that that really that
really got to me and you know watching
these two connect and see one of them be
scared then see the other one be scared
and see the level of which they're
compared you're prepared to commit to it
and the way that it ends with with Kelly
deciding to go into sand you know peril
you don't want to reminded me of it
reminded me a little bit of the very
last episode of Futurama spoiler alert
for that I guess but the very end of
that Fry and Leela basically have been
the world was frozen in a moment of time
but they are still moving freely through
it and they're moving through it and
they're aging and they're traveling this
time of frozen world just experiencing
everything that that they can and then
eventually the professor you know finds
them and goes hey I can bring you back
you won't remember any of this and
you're gonna start over again and
there's there's something about fried
looks really is what do you say do you
want to go around again and there was
something about Kelly saying okay I
think I'm ready for everything else you
know her saying that line before herself
becoming a permanent resident of San
Junipero it struck that same emotional
note for me so that was this was just
this was just really nice and had a lot
of nice touches throughout like I as
much as it was very drenched in the 80s
it was nice to see it at least touch on
other eras and and see you know all the
nineties all the 2000s stuff just just
oozing from every frame when we saw
those eras that was kind of fun the
quagmire hate her that was um that was
interesting can I just say it's really
annoying at least as depicted in in TV
and movies that those kinds of clubs I
find myself going okay
kind of wish it wasn't such crap music
cuz it's it's always this you know harsh
screamy death metal kind of sudden like
can we get some badly at least some less
you're bleeding music cuz otherwise this
seems kind of cool
but obviously you know it's it's it's
the it's the hedonistic side of San
Junipero which is I think a very good
thing to show exists in this space cuz
it would and just a lot of little
acknowledgments about how everything
worked your references to having your
pain settings turned down the the way
the the midnight the you know the five
hour trial run is over for the people
who are just visiting that guy used
really effectively at a few different
points and I get I think a lot of credit
is owed to the writing for these two
characters in the way that they're
performed because if if you don't buy
this relationship
then you don't buy this episode because
the relationship is the episode and I
did buy it and I was I was touched by it
I was moved by it and ah honestly the
day that I watched it I kind of needed
it I I it was it wasn't the best day but
this this helped kind of wrap it up on a
nice huh it's just kind of sweet note
and it had more than a few points
throughout that
yeah little little waterworks cuz I am a
I am I huge friggin wimp if he can hit
me in the right fields and this did so
San Junipero to compare it to the other
uplifting black mare episode that I mean
uplifting thoroughly yeah you could
argue honestly that nosedive at least
ends on a ironically uplifting note but
to compare to hang the DJ I do like this
one better and it's it's I don't I'm not
sure I have it in me to rank all the
black mirror episodes by the time I
finish this of course now that I've said
that I probably will just because that's
what always happens like I say I'm not
gonna do that and then I end up doing it
but this this will be up there this was
good and and I watched it at the right
time
I needed it today and it's just nice
saying Junipero what were your thoughts
on this particular episode album black
mirror or whatever they are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's all the stuff to
do like support me on patreon follow me
on Twitter listen to my podcast etc etc
lease for all that stuff is down in the
description so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]